E aí
[Música]
se você já parou para pensar que todo
mundo tá aqui porque alguém teve um
ciclo menstrual
e esse processo fisiológico necessário
para gerar vida é considerado por muitas
associações de ginecologia do mundo todo
como quinto sinal Vital junto com o
temperatura a pressão batimento cardíaco
respiração
portanto esse assunto diz respeito a
todos nós é sobre saúde física mental
emocional e mais sobre Equidade de
gênero e dignidade humana portanto uma
pasta de saúde pública para essa
conversa vamos entender que ciclo
menstrual é tudo o que acontece do
primeiro dia de uma menstruação até a
véspera da outra e vamos dividir aqui em
três etapas a regida pelo hormônio
estrogênio a regida pelo hormônio
progesterona EA menstrual ao contrário
do que a maioria de nós aprendeu esses
hormônios não atuam só no nosso sistema
reprodutor mas também na nossa pele e
nos cabelos na classificação dos nossos
ossos na nossa cognição e no nosso
comportamento e são essas duas o que eu
quero explorar um pouco com vocês aqui
cada pessoa vive e percebe seu ciclo de
forma individual a partir do seu
contexto da sua história da sua rotina
incluindo condições de sono alimentação
atividades físicas relações
profissionais familiares
Mas existe uma tendência sugerida pelos
hormônios de que na fase proliferativa A
regida pelo estrogênio que vai dar nossa
menstruação até a nossa ovulação que a
gente sinta mas
energia física mais foco mais disposição
raciocínio mais linear nessa fase os
neurotransmissores dopamina e serotonina
são também elevados trazendo maior
sensação de bem-estar já o progesterona
que rege o nosso ciclo da ovulação até
um pouquinho antes da menstruação
tem um efeito levemente sedativo
levemente relaxante
a energia física se apresenta em Picos o
raciocínio fica mais fluido o foco se
volta para outras necessidades tem de
aparecer uma necessidade maior de
introspecção E essas características na
sociedade da performance e da
produtividade são assumidas como ruins
porque atrapalhariam essa forma de
produção como a gente não se conhece
como também deusa no período menstrual
os níveis desses hormônios diminui e
tende a parecer necessidade de diminuir
o ritmo não só para as pessoas que têm
dores e desconfortos nessa fase é uma
dança hormonal fisiológica humana mas a
omissão ver esse conhecimento a falta de
visibilidade e educação menstrual faz
com que essas pessoas se sintam culpadas
frustradas incompetentes em constantes
nós temos um modelo sociocultural que
determina é estar bem e a gente busca
utopicamente está sempre nesse padrão
comportamental
ignora que é impossível e inumano viver
dessa forma
oprime invalida as nossas necessidades
mais íntimas vai contra a nossa natureza
fisiológica
cíclica detona Nossa autoestima o nosso
potencial pessoal e profissional uma
pessoa que menstrua tem em média 400
ciclos ao longo da vida isso acontece no
período onde ela é estudante e
profissional parte do mercado de
trabalho isso acontece em qualquer
geolocalização qualquer cultura qualquer
classe social
menstruamos desde que existimos como
humanidade
mulheres seus homens trans pessoas
não-binárias mas só nos últimos anos ou
meses que o assunto tem ganha
visibilidade
a parte de uma luta de mulheres
reivindicando o seu direito de existir
de forma digna
Olá você que menstrua ou convive com
alguém que menstrua já observou essas
oscilações de ânimo de comportamento de
humor e se você não tivesse acesso a
absorventes como você iria para a escola
ou para o trabalho
e sem esses produtos diminuem os laços
sociais e a oportunidade de
independência a cada dez pessoas quatro
vivem em situação de pobreza menstrual a
cada quatro crianças uma perna de aula
por falta de acesso a produtos de
higiene e educação menstrual
considerando que uma pessoa que menstrua
tem esse sangramento entre 3 a 5 dias
por mês ou às vezes até 7 horas e os
dias úteis do mês de aulas são 20 essa
pessoa perde em média 25 por cento das
suas aulas e da sua interação social
perde ela que não têm as mesmas
condições que os outros alunos para
desenvolver a totalidade da sua
capacidade e perdemos nós a oportunidade
de ver essa capacidade de crescer se
desenvolver e atuar em prol da sociedade
e também perdemos em saúde muitas
pessoas crianças em situação de
vulnerabilidade
pessoas do sistema carcerário recorre a
tecidos velhos
absorventes usados sabe miolo de pão
gerando risco imenso de infecção
necessitando de atendimento na rede
pública Quando consegue
elevando ainda risco de morte ainda que
algumas iniciativas estejam se
mobilizando para encontrar uma forma
mais saudável e biodegradável a
distribuição de absorventes descartáveis
É nesse momento a única que a gente tem
para oferecer
é extremamente poluente toneladas de
lixo químicas branqueadoras na produção
nocivo para o nosso corpo para as nossas
águas para o nosso solo para o nosso
planeta
Entretanto a maioria das pessoas em
situação de pobreza menstrual não têm
acesso a água nem para beber e nem para
cozinhar nem para tomar banho Quem dirá
para higienizar corretamente coletores
absorventes de pano e mesmo se tivesse
os tabus e os estigmas sobre esse corpo
e sobre esse sangue que ainda visto com
nojo com vergonha com medo até uma
semântica
um pouco se fala sobre menstruação e
quando se fala é com o uso de eufemismos
tá naqueles dias tá de chico tá de boi
tá na lua nesse momento de visibilidade
e reparo Educacional falar a palavra
menstruação se faz necessário menstruar
é um processo fisiológico necessário a
nossa saúde a manutenção da nossa
espécie E desde antes de Cristo é vista
como perigosa como suja como vergonhosa
mesmo que todos nós só estejamos aqui
desde o início da humanidade Por que
alguém teve um ciclo menstrual então
considerando esse pensamento opressor uh
imagina uma pessoa que mora numa
comunidade numa casa com outras 15
pessoas como que ela lava o absorvente
de pano e pendura no varal no sol para
secar
E como que ela ferve e genes ali no fogo
um coletor e coletor nem é para todo
mundo nem é tudo corpo que essa data
Então nesse momento a distribuição de
absorventes descartáveis é uma
alternativa
emergencial para que a gente consiga
comentar um pouco de dignidade na vida
dessas pessoas até que a gente consiga
oferecer
saneamento educação e em somos menos
tóxicos então você que menstrua e tem
acesso a alternativas sustentáveis tem o
dever de deixar os descartáveis para
quem não tem
promover esses insumos conjuntamente com
educação sexual e menstrual e
distribuição de renda é questão de saúde
pública de todos nós de investimento em
saúde e futuro obrigada
E aí